à une semaine d'élections législatives
très indécises
il a promis d'annexer une partie
stratégique de la cisjordanie s'il était
riche d'un podium verglas temime
navarette strictes à leipheimer navires
mistral razorlight qui a collaboré
bernard werber même vachement plus de
600 mille colons israéliens vivent
aujourd'hui en cisjordanie souvent
derrière un mur ou une enceinte protéger
militairement par israël une question
agite désormais la campagne électorale
et la communauté internationale
ces territoires occupés seront ils
bientôt annexé 9 avril 2019
en israël le feuilleton des législatives
prend fin netanyahu gagne les élections
sur le fil face à son principal rival
béni dans ce zelda emma chanuc sharon à
des abus
mais la joie n'est que de courte durée
israël étant une démocratie
parlementaire netanyahu doit forger des
alliances pour rassembler derrière lui
une majorité de sièges à la knesset
autrement impossible de faire passer des
lois mais le premier ministre a essuyé
le refus d' avigdor lieberman un allié
de poids sur lequel il comptait et a
donc finalement échoué à former sa
coalition
c'est donc le retour aux urnes et aux
promesses de campagne mais cette fois ci
netanyahu durci ses discours et ajuste
son pari électoral
alors d'abord il se présente comme un
homme de dimension internationale
l'ami des grands de poutine de train et
cette dimension lui permet de dire c'est
moi qui vais vous protéger contre les
agressions extérieures
après il ya ce à sa dénonciation de
l'establishment médiatique qui est de
plus en plus violentes et ensuite il ya
aussi sont son alliance qu'il a cherché
à conforter avec la droite et d'extrême
droite sioniste et là effectivement on
peut on va sur le terrain des colonies
notamment
il faut plus qu'un coup d'oeil pour
comprendre l'enjeu des colonies en
cisjordanie des territoires sont de
facto annexé par israël comme jérusalem
est depuis 1967 des territoires sont
immédiatement annexe abl regardez le
tracé du mur déjà construits ou en train
de l'être qui grignote la frontière et
puis il existe des dizaines de petites
colonies éparpillées un peu partout en
cisjordanie et militairement bien gardé
dans tous ces territoires occupés par
israël illégalement au regard du droit
international
six cent mille colons se sont donné pour
mission de vivre sur une terre qu'ils
estiment être la leur autre chose à
savoir la cisjordanie est divisée
en deux grandes zones la zone c'est ici
en bleu foncé qui est déjà sous contrôle
de l'armée israélienne et les zones a et
b en bleu clair qui sont administrés par
l'autorité palestinienne
les colonies grossistes de plus en plus
les blocs de colonies grossistes donc
elles deviennent de plus en plus
irréversible
on ne peut absolument pas les bouger et
puis les cette annonce de benyamin
nétanyahou mais qui date de la première
campagne électorale pour les élections
d'avril qui affirme éclat terme il
voudrait annexer les colonies ou buzz
rattaché à marc coma rhume est harry
potter ou d alcool jeux s'ouvrent donc
il ya quand même un flou autour de 7,2
cette annonce puisque certains y ont vu
les prémices d'une annexion de la zone c
voire de l'annexion de toute la
cisjordanie alors je pense que le flou a
été maintenu volontairement pour essayer
de capter plus largement un électorat
soit l'électorat qui voudraient annexer
les colonies soit l'électorat qui
voudraient aller au delà qui voudraient
le grand israël
l'annexion de l'ensemble de la
cisjordanie et ça c'est volontairement
pour capter les voix des colons et de
l'extrême droite
l'avenir des colonies est devenu un axe
dominants de la campagne électorale le
31 juillet israël valley d'un important
projet de 6000 nouveaux logements
israéliens en cisjordanie et en
contrepartie l'état hébreu à cordes 700
permis de construire aux palestiniens le
4 septembre netanyahu se rend à hébron
une ville au sud de la cisjordanie où
les tensions sont toujours très vive
avec les palestiniens
le 10 septembre il va encore plus loin
et promet d'annexer la vallée du
jourdain
s'il est élu
le pari électoral de netanyahou est de
ramener ce vote
collomb dans sa coalition le vote
collomb est à s'éparpiller c'est dire
que la sociologie aussi des colons est
assez est assez diverses donc une partie
des colons votre quand même pour le
likoud pour benyamin nétanyahou et une
autre partie éclaté entre les différents
partis de droite que nous on appellerait
d'extrême droite et pro colons les
colons et ceux qui soutiennent la
colonisation forme donc une masse
électorale disparates
ils se reconnaissent dans des nuances de
droite et d'extrême droite mais ils
divergent par exemple sur le degré de
religiosité voulu dans la société mais
au fait que ni benny gantz l'ancien chef
d'état major et principal rival de
netanyahu sur la question des colonies
sur le sujet gagnent c'est flou et ne
parle pas de d'annexion mais ne parle
pas non plus de retrait complet parfois
il évoque un retrait partiel
si on parvenait un plan de paix et un
accord sur tout avec les palestiniens
ou qu'elle ait une ne semble pas croire
en fait ils cherchent surtout amène à se
ménager de l'électorat de droite dont il
espère siphonner les bois les campagnes
électorales sont toujours un moment
idéal pour les promesses intenables mais
sur cette question de l'annexion la
conjoncture actuelle pourrait permettre
à netanyahou s'il remporte le scrutin de
tenir parole
au risque d'embraser encore un peu plus
la région en cas de victoire de
netanyahou il ya effectivement une forte
probabilité d'annexion pour une raison
très simple c'est que netanyahu va
bénéficier d'une d'une fenêtre de tir
historique est inédite et cela grâce au
soutien des états unis au soutien de
train pour rentrer je me targue d'avoir
avons appris la terrible nouvelle souvim
on vers un crime
mme bertheaume mehr avait eu mort
d'homme but s'il a une chance de pouvoir
un excès les colonies ce sera lors de
son prochain mandat
s'il a une coalition élargie à droite il
a toutes les cartes en main pour pouvoir
le faire
la question c'est jusqu'où va-t-il aller
est-ce que c'est uniquement une annexion
des colonies c'est à dire les ramener
sous
sous la législation israélienne sous la
souveraineté pleine et entière
israélienne et non plus une
administration civile à part des
territoires ou alors il ira un peu plus
loin dans une annexion des zones c c'est
à dire que là ils empiètent sur une
annexion véritablement des territoires
palestiniens